qu'ils avaient d'autres encore tout le
monde était là à l'aise à la avec
cendres il n'est pas marqué avec centre
à cinq ans à sa naissance un manque
d'oxygène à créer des lésions cérébrales
conduisant à une tetra paresi une forme
d'infirmité moteur cérébral la petite
fille est suivi par plusieurs praticiens
à l'hôpital raymond-poincaré de garches
aujourd'hui après l'école elle a rendez
vous avec laeticia son ergothérapeute
qui la suit depuis trois ans c'est une
petite fille qui présente de grosses
difficultés motrices de grosses
difficultés de coordination motrice sur
l'ensemble du corps y compris sur la
sphère bucco faciale une des priorités
aussi chez cette petite ça c'est de
pouvoir pouvoir s'exprimer pouvoir
communiquer avec son entourage
l'objectif de ces séances d'ergothérapie
rendre autonomes et indépendantes la
petite fille dans les activités de la
vie quotidienne
jeudi 7 mars jeudi 7 avril
jeudi 7 avril pour ces séances
anaïs utilise une synthèse vocale il
tablette qui permet à l'enfant de
communiquer et d'avoir de vraies
conversations
en fait c'est des combinaisons de
pictogrammes qui vont nous permettre
d'aller dans différents différents
registres
on va pouvoir conjuguer tous les verbes
à cet endroit là toute la ligne du haut
ça va être
des catégories les habits les animaux la
nourriture voilà on va voir tous les
petits mots de liaison qui vont être en
verre etc le fait d'apprendre toutes les
combinaisons des pictogrammes qui
qui va pouvoir permettre une
conversation après fonctionnel avec des
mots de liaison avec on peut enregistrer
des phrases on peut faire plein plein de
choses et on peut tout dire surtout un
appareil qui coûte plus de 8000 euros
mais indispensable à la petite fille
pour lui permettre de mieux communiquer
en marche de l'école anaïs suit des
séances d'orthophonie kinésithérapie
ergothérapie ainsi que divers soins à
l'hôpital des semaines très lourde pour
une petite fille pleine de vie